just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years what
is one thing that they would carry with
them the Quran why because they did not
have it on their mobile devices or their
gadgets brothers and sisters imagine you
have a app the Quran app which not only
shows you how much rewards you get but
reminds you to read the Quran gives you
reminders download the Quran app now and
let it testify for you on that you read
it wherever you was
[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends
today we're going to be reacting to an
ex Hamas supporter was he an exus
supporter or an ex humus supporter the
brother asked a very good question we're
going to find out inshallah this
individual I'm very familiar with him
because he was one of these individuals
about 5 10 years ago when this whole
ex-muslim thing was popping off Etc and
now it's all died down and they are
finished they can't make any more uh
videos um one thing that caught my
attention when he used to talk it was he
would talk about key things he was an
Excell
um he's now a non-practicing homosexual
it's not H cuz they asked him did you
ever kiss a guy he said no I haven't
done that yet I'm just homosexual uh but
his story was in a nutshell just your
typical ex-muslim story of this happened
that happened you know I'm gay and then
I got some DS and I left no problem but
for some odd reason GB news invites him
as this ex hamus supporter who has some
intelligence that he wants to share with
the world I think they with people like
this you know what they do bro they just
use them yes they just there as like a
humus silky creamy
humus sorry
humus don't laugh at him he's a serious
guy watch so they got issue with salais
oh he used to be an ex salae they they
got an issue with Muslims with regards
to homosexuality oh he's a homosexual as
well now they got an issue with Hamas
silky creamy humus he seems to be ready
for everything yeah I used to be that as
well M yeah that me I used to do that
back in the days as well he identifies
as everything yes but for now it's ham
everything that these guys see let's see
with the narrative has always been
turning against Israel let's see what GB
news has for us cuz they might have
stuff in they must have done some
background research and invited an
academic who's at Oxford I think is at
Oxford let's see what this ex Hamas
member supporter has to say yeah
definitely definitely great to have you
in the studio so thank you for joining
us how did you get sucked into being a
Hamas supporter see it started at a very
young age I was radicalized from the age
six dang onwards um which some people
might find surprising you don't think of
people being radicalized at such a young
age but I was um and I was raised with
this hate filled ideology whereby I
believe Britain was the enemy I believed
that non-muslims are in a Perpetual war
against Muslims it's just the standard
extremist islamist kind of ideology that
I was just raised
in if I saw him on the road I would I
would say he's a supporter of food yes I
would I would think he sells homus silky
creamy hummus he looks like a genuine F
humus seller on the street like you know
in those little Caravans and you know
what's very interesting I watched his
videos before and now not a single place
he ever mentions he was a hamus
supporter ever but for some odd reason
GB news invites him and he is an ex
hamus supporter the problem with GB news
is that why are they this is clearly a
political issue yeah why are they
bringing on to say oh I'm an ex Muslim
and I used to Doo how is that relevant
to the conversation you know what that's
that's actually islamophobic that's what
that is because the issue is to do with
settler colonialism it's got nothing to
do with the fact that Bob over here used
to be a copy you're not sopy and you're
not sopy I'm the sopy let's see what he
has to say he must have some very key
intelligence well if they bought this
guy on then I mean he clearly doesn't
meet the visual image so don't judge a
book by his cover he must have some deep
intelligence I'm and it says the big
story on there as well exactly I didn't
think Hamas has a wing in in the UK I've
been a Muslim for 10 years I've been in
private circles classes Muslim families
you name it I wow you're so Pious I am I
have never ever ever come across anybody
for that matter talking about oh we hate
the West oh we yes of course we hate the
actions they did in Iraq and Afghanistan
whatever B and anyone that's human would
hate that nobody has ever me or
radicalized me to think that Britain is
my enemy and I have to hate them at the
age of six at the age of six Muslim kids
are memorize the Quran they're not told
and be like hey sit down here listen you
hate the west and we need to we hate the
Jews and we hate everyone what no we
don't exactly that's my point no but you
just said we hate the West no that's
what telling your kid that's not the
case is it family members or friends or
people you didn't know that were
grooming you in this way it was my
parents in fact um they had themselves
become extreme yeah uh what's did this
group get you to do I mean did you
actively participate in any way did you
attend meetings what what was your what
was your sort of role with this grouping
um absolutely I I wasn't involved in any
sort of group per se I was always kind
of on my own are you
lonely okay what ideology he goes I was
not per se involved in any group I was a
Lo he's not he's not in a group yeah
he's a loner yes and I mean what
credibility to be honest like what
what's the point of bringing some loner
that lives in his mom's basement yes
eating
humus do you think he got hamus confused
with humus I genuinely believe this you
know what I'm the more I'm listening to
this guy the more I'm actually swinging
to your your side of before I was like
why what's why is he keep talking about
he can't he's asking what's the ideology
okay what is his ideology he's
conflating Islam with a silky creamy
homus
what was the trigger that inspired you
to walk away from this ideology it was a
number of things um but Chief among them
it was my understanding evolutionary
biology um so science saved you science
did indeed save me um but I realized
that contradicted my entire ideology and
I was forced then to change my entire
world just unraveled because you learned
about the origins of humanity via nature
and this contradicted the theology uh ex
preached by by L
hamers
what contradicted his whole Theology and
you know made him question why he
supported Hamas was him studying the
theory of evolution yeah and cuz Hamas
talks about the Hamas talks about
Evolution yeah and and he was like this
goes against my uh belief system they
put that in their Charter in it like
that's something that's very integral to
their political efforts yes Evolution
yeah what Charles Darwin said and the
homoerectus exactly and that really
contradicted his belief in why you
laughing
because yeah homus is a thing yes it
definitely is you get excit he looks he
looks like he probably get excited by
that he looks like that the point is
what hamus got to do with Evolution and
him not supporting them anymore please
make sense no it's because of
Homer
Go I mean that's what it is but it gets
more interesting and Sinister when he
has An Occurrence when he's walking down
the road and he sees a young Jewish kid
wow and and look what transpires be be
ready because it's a deep story yo yo
changed his whole life I went to a
Jewish home um I was selling a computer
to them and the little toddler they had
a little kid came up to me and suddenly
just became attached to me and the
parent said he wants to play with you so
I was really young I sat down and
started playing with his toy cars and
his parents were looking on on what was
happening and smiling and I remember
looking across at them and thinking I
hate them but they don't hate
me in fact they're trusting me with
their child and that changed a lot for
me just just just just just imagine this
for a second yeah I don't know what kind
of Islam or idea that he was living by
no so so this lonely guy is playing with
the stranger's child and is no either
you're lonely or you play with you know
random kids like you need to make your
mind up no it doesn't make sense bro
just imagine he goes into this house or
whatever he's playing with the child
he's playing cars with the kid here for
some odd reason he can you imagine going
no he's a kid he plays cars isn't it
whatever for that matter look at the
story he goes to this house for he's
selling them yeah the house walking bar
and he ends up playing with a kid and
then he's like I hate no not with the
kid like he's playing with the cars
playing with the cars yeah with the
child yeah and he goes I hate them and
they don't hate me bro there was a
Jewish man who got attacked in Stanford
deil I went and done a video not once
have iing the brother asked a very good
question no defending him against the
attacker hope the answer the question
not once did I ever thought to myself I
have je people who I speak to I have
jewi like there certain who come to the
park we speak to I've been to Hill I've
been into their synagogue yeah not once
have I ever been taught through Islam or
anything for that matter that I have to
hate Jews so to me this story is
absolutely bull crap bro that you went
there like oh I hate them but they don't
hate me that's not the Islam that's been
taught to anybody for that matter there
is nothing in Islam nowhere in Islam
that tells us to hate the Jews none zero
the prophet's wife was ethnically Jewish
so for us to hate Jewish people it's as
good as hating my own mother so the
matter at hand you can see how it's
distorted and how perverted he is that
he's making up this story that have
nothing to do with religion of course
critics of isra Israel would argue that
Israel has a case to answer for its
treatment of the Palestinian people what
would you say to that I would say that
before other people got involved
internationally I would kind of caution
against that because
what often this conflict is viewed in
black and white terms and a lot of
people kind of lose their mind over it
um it's they have a caricature idea of
it good guy versus bad guy very trial
whoa whoa whoa hold up time out time out
exactly it's very tribalistic and the
conflict is very complicated it's got
mult we want to end on this guy this
here this is so fundamental here Allah
subhana wa tala talks about the
psychology of the mus of thef of thef of
the
M very interesting bro if you look go to
the Ayah when Allah talks about those
who turn their back against in religion
Allah will replace them and Allah say
something very specific he says and they
do not care about the blame of the blame
uh blamers meaning what this guy is such
an Uncle Tom to the level where he's
like yeah I'm Pro Britain Pro this he
does not even mention the killing and
the massacre and the genocide of the
Palestinian kids so much so that the GB
news presenter who is also probably
pro-israeli has to interject just so he
can be fair and say you know what about
what about Israel and you know their
treatment of the Palestinians and what
does he say nothing no condemnation bro
Allah subhana wa ta'ala spoke the H
these individuals hate the blame he's
such a he's sucking up to the white man
so badly he's not even uttering it so
much so that his master the white man
sitting opposite him which he wants to
lick his toes is there mentioning Israel
and his treatment of Palestinians can
you imagine at least the disbeliever
opposite him has more of a unbiased some
little form of unbiasedness and what
does he say no mention no condemnation
he's just saying both sides same waffly
arguments that don't really make sense
in fact it doesn't even answer the point
the fact that you can't even condemn
just because of your overlords are going
to you know take away that pay packet
you're not going to be invited again and
you're going to be more irrelevant than
you actually are and your mushroom head
you look like a mushroom you're a humus
you look like a humus the that's what
you look like you look like an absolute
humus that's what you are you claim you
left Islam and I've watched your videos
nowhere in those videos you talking
about your story of leaving Islam you
ever mention Hamas you humus that's what
you are you're a liar you're a froster
you're an intellectual fraud you're
intellectually bankrupt you are finished
like Muhammad hijab says you are an
absolute coward you went on there did
not condemn Israel once seeing the
killing of innocent babies and children
you are a heartless coward a sellout an
Uncle Tom that's what you are shame on
you and that's all I have to say there's
nothing else I can say and your story is
an absolute fraud and it shows that
Israel is such on the back for that GB
news had no one to bring but an absolute
Coward of a humus like you any last
words isan salamu alaykum waum Salam